on en vient la situation en Ukraine les
ministres des Affaires étrangères des
pays de l'OTAN étaient réunis hier mardi
à Bruxelles le secrétaire général de
l'Alliance yen stottenberg se montre
confiant sur la poursuite du soutien
militaire à Kief notamment l'aide
américaine mais il reconnaît une
situation difficile sur le champ de
bataille on en parle ce matin avec notre
correspondant à Kief bonjour Guliver
Krag Guliver cette situation difficile
c'est notamment le front de l'Est
oui c'est surtout autour de la ville d'
ka les Russes ont monté une troème vague
d'assaut en engageant des quantités de
forces très impressionnantes et en
subissant des pertes très
impressionnantes jusqu'à 1000 soldats
par jour tués selon les renseignements
britanniques tués ou blessés grav sans
succès selon la ligne officielle
ukrainienne qui dit que les forces
ukrainiennes tiennent la ligne et
continuent de tenir cette ville presque
entièrement détruite mais très
stratégiquement située juste au nord de
Donetsk qui est contrôlé par les russes
depuis 2014 en vérité si on lit les
interviews que certains militaires
Ukrainiens donnent à la presse ces
derniers jours et notamment une tribune
écrit par Oleg sensov le céas qui avait
été emprisonné en Russie pendant
quelques années avant d'être libéré et
qui a dernièrement rejoint les forces
armées de l'Ukraine eux disent que la
situation est beaucoup plus difficile et
que les forces russes sont entrées dans
la zone industrielle au Sud-Est
d'avdivka qui était vraiment la
forteresse ukrainienne la seule partie
de la ligne de front qui n'avait pas
bougé d'un cm depuis le début de
l'invasion à grande échelle en février
2022 c'était la ligne de front entre
2014 et
2023 maintenant visiblement les forces
russes sont dans cette zone industrielle
qui est très grande hein ils sont loin
de contrôler toute la zone mais le fait
qu'ils ont pénétré cette forteresse
ukrainienne selon de nombreux analystes
est très inquiétant euh pour euh
l'avenir de la défense ukrainienne de
cette ville bonjour Guliver il y a aussi
cette affaire dont on parle beaucoup ces
dernières heures en Ukraine keV
soupçonne Moscou d'avoir empoisonné
l'épouse d'un chef du Renseignement
ukrainien
oui c'est Marian boudanova la épouse du
chef des renseignements militaires
kirilo Kiril Boudanov qui est un homme
extrêmement populaire en Ukraine il est
populaire en partie en tout cas à cause
de sa langue très asserbe ses critiques
envers Vladimir Poutine qui sont d'après
des analystes considérés par le kremelin
comme vraiment des des des calomnies des
insultes et que c'est pour cela que le
kremelin aurait voulu avoir sa vengeance
bien sûr c'est quelque chose qui
inquiète beaucoup en Ukraine on sait que
la Russie par le passé a déjà eu recours
à l'empoisonnement de personnes situées
en dehors de la Russie euh qu'elle
considérait comme des ennemis c'est
peut-être un invertissement euh pour
Boudanov lui-même qui a déjà dit dans de
nombreuses interviews qu'il pense que
euh Moscou voudrait le tuer je pense
qu'il convient de souligner tout de même
que ces informations nous parviennent
uniquement euh de sources ukrainienne de
des renseignements militaires Ukrainiens
eux-mêmes c'est beaucoup beaucoup
discuté dans les médias euh Ukrainiens
mais on n'a pas d'enquête indépendant
pour vérifier qu'est-ce qui y est
vraiment arrivé en tout cas euh elle
serait à l'hôpital et elle serait en
train de être soignée visiblement sa vie
n'est pas en danger mais les
renseignements militaires disent que
elle n'était pas la seule personne visée
d'autres agents aussi auraient été
empoisonnés avec des métals lourdes
Guliver pour revenir sur le conflit les
belligérants poursuivent l'effort de
guerre les présidents russes et
ukrainiens viennent tous deux de de
valider une hausse de leur budget
militaire et alors le chèque de Moscou
est bien plus important que que celui de
Kief
oui bien sûr l'économie russe est plus
grande que l'économie ukrainienne et il
faut savoir aussi que les 65 millions
dans le budget fédéral sont seulement
une partie des défenses militaires
russes parce qu'une autre partie vient
des budgets régional pour l'Ukraine
c'est 43 milliards du budget national
mais bien sûr le pays compte aussi sur
des dizaines de milliards
supplémentaires en soutien venant des
États-Unis l'Ukraine attend de voir si
Joe Biden réussira à faire approuver par
le Congrès sa dernière proposition
octroyer encore plusieurs dizaines de
milliards de dollars en soutien à
l'Ukraine